hot breath i really like uh performing
in
minnesota that's a great like i think
the people there are really good
uh i do the mall of amer uh rick
bronson's house of comedy
and i really liked it but i do i've been
going there for years and uh
i like that i like the people there you
know i really do because people come
from all over the place
comedy on state and wisconsin is great
the dc
improv is a great place um
you know and the the areas are good but
it's also um
it also depends what kind of club it is
if it's a good club and the club is well
run
then the clientele that comes in will be
better regardless of the area yep
yeah yeah i've heard great things about
comedy on state and the the minnesota
one was it
is that the acme one is that acme or is
that
no this is uh this is i've never been to
the acme one although i've heard good
things is that minneapolis
okay the house okay yeah that's right
you said rick bronson's house of comedy
okay
yeah very nice yeah it's funny also like
the stress factory
the stress factory in uh new brunswick
new jersey and uh
the one in bridgeport connecticut
there's two he has two of them now
um those are very good
no i know you didn't say any comedy
zones there you don't like
doing have you ever done comedy zone
games yeah comedy zone i've never done a
comedy stone i'm not
really i'm not in the improv so oh okay
that's what i had been i had started to
do more of those last year i was
starting to get
some more um work thrown at me from that
angle in terms of getting more road gigs
like that which
some are some are better than others you
know um
regardless the money is never great
but right i guess that's part of it you
know i'm
i just hit my 10 year mark so i've been
and last year was really my big step
into
headlining more and like getting on
stage for that
45 minutes and really having to like
establish
and sustain yourself on stage so
getting to comedy zones and performing
around outside of my immediate area was
it's been a good learning experience
both on stage but then also from the
business side
you know what i mean yeah
right it's going to be interesting how
this how many clubs i hope they could
stay afloat yeah
how this refigures you know for sure
you